bonjour troisième et dernier débat avant
le premier tour des élections
départementales qui aura lieu le 22 mars
les rédactions de france 3 basse
normandie ouest france et france bleu
basse-normandie s'associent pour vous
permettre de mieux comprendre les enjeux
de ce scrutin et les différences entre
les candidats coup de projecteur
aujourd'hui sur le département du
calvados un département où la majorité
de centre-droit ne semblent pas en
danger mais quel sera le poids du ps et
du front national dans ce scrutin la
gauche part divisée
nous allons débattre à mes côtés pour
animer cette émission philippe thomas
rédacteur en chef adjoint de france bleu
basse-normandie bonjour philippe bonjour
france et guillaume bayart directeur de
ouest-france calvados bonjour guillaume
bonjour pour ce troisième rendez vous on
accueille sur ce plateau jean léonce
dupont sénateur udi et président sortant
du conseil général vous remettez votre
monde en jeu bonjour bonjour
clotilde valter députés socialistes et
chef de file de l'opposition au
département vous avez été désigné
porte-parole de ces élections bonjour
cédric nouvelot secrétaire départemental
de l'ump
vous êtes également membre du bureau
national de l'ump où joueront jour
également candidat également candidate
christelle le chevalier vous êtes
secrétaire départemental du front
national dans lequel va deux bonjour et
francis joly candidats et porte parole
d'europe écologie les verts bonjour
bonjour il ajoute que nous entendrons
dans un instant marie-claude airblue qui
est responsable départemental du front
de gauche
le dessinateur chaunu nous accompagnent
bonjour chaunu franck je suis en retard
parce qu'ils savaient que c'est assez
compliqué à comprendre c'est
départementale que va peser notre petit
département face à ces cohortes de
légionnaires venus de haute normandie
puisque après les départementales il va
y avoir les régionales est ce que bien
qu en existera encore et le calvados ça
je ne sais pas mais bien voir avec dans
quelques instants je rappelle simplement
que ces élections départementales ont
lieu les 22 et 29 mars que le mode de
scrutin était modifiée puisque vous
élirez des binômes un homme une femme
sur chaque canton des cantons qui ont
été redécoupée
et il y en a deux fois moins qu'avant
dans le calvados on va passer de 49 à 25
cantons on peut dire que ça n'est pas
toujours bien compris des électeurs
justement comment convaincre les gens de
se rendre aux urnes le 22 mars prochain
je m'adressais d'abord tia clotilde
valter pour le parti socialiste
à ce jour près de 6 électeurs sur 10
n'auraient pas l'intention d'aller voter
c'est ce que l'on dit quand on voit les
sondages
que dites vous aux électeurs je leur dis
qu'il faut se mobiliser aller voter
évidemment parce qu'ils ont le droit de
le droit de voter leur devoir de
citoyens de participer à la désignation
de leurs de leurs élus jouer quand même
aussi rajouter que des élections locales
ont traditionnellement une participation
moindre ont nettement moindre que
certaines certaines autres élections
et si on compare aux échéances
précédentes on était dans une situation
qui était certes certes meilleur mais
que ce que nous regrettions aussi les
mêmes à la même place ou pas
complètement je suis dit encore le 52%
des français sont favorables à la
suppression des départements
dans un récent sondage ouest-france ce
que ça vous inquiète tout simplement ce
sondage
mais moi ça me surprend pas parce que
c'est le deuxième élément que j'allais
que j'allais abordé c'est que les
français ne comprennent rien à notre
carte territoriale et à notre
organisation territoriale ça n'est pas
lisible
il sait pas ce qu'ils savent pas ce que
font les communautés de communes les
divers syndicats le département la
région le maintenant il ya le pôle
métropolitain il ya un tas de structures
qui s'empilent
on ne comprend pas et deuxièmement ça
leur donne une impression d'inefficacité
savent pas comment ça marche
pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils votent dans
un dispositif où ils ne savent pas
comment ça marche et qui fait quoi alors
on va répartir le temps de parole pour
essayer d'être équitable au maximum
jusqu'à la fin de l'émission et que vous
ayez la possibilité de vous exprimer sur
tous les thèmes questions de guillaume
bayart de ouest france
est ce que l'un des problèmes aussi de
compréhension ne vient pas du fait de la
réforme territoriale ou à une semaine
finalement de cette élection
on ne connaît toujours pas précisément
quelles seront les compétences dévolues
qui au département
et aux conseils régionaux et une réponse
de jean léonce dupont pour lui dire bon
et c'est vrai que la période est pas
simple on nous a annoncé d'abord le
maintien ensuite la suppression puis à
nouveau le maintien on a changé la
circonscription électorale
on a changé le mode de scrutin et nous
ne sommes pas vous avez raison de le
dire à dix jours conscient de l'ensemble
des compétences qui vont être les nôtres
reconnaissez que c'est quand même un
petit peu surréaliste et qu'il ya eu
énormément d'improvisation qui plus est
les réformes terra territoria
successives n'ont pas abouti à la
simplification comme a priori c'était
l'objectif poursuivi mais plutôt à une
complexité croissante
vous avez en plus de ce qui existait
déjà les métropoles les pôles
métropolitains et autres structures
comment voulez-vous que effectivement il
soit facile pour les habitants de se
faire une idée
alors l'enjeu parce que l'enjeu c'est
quoi c'est de savoir le 22 et le 29 mars
comment décider d'envoyer les élus les
plus aptes à représenter leur territoire
leur canton les plus aptes à gérer à
l'assemblée départementale dans les
compétences de la de l'assemblée
départementale et les plus aptes à
porter une loi fort de ce département
dans la réorganisation régionale qui est
en train effectivement sensor il y à
l'enjeu politique également enjeu local
vous l'avez exprimé jean léonce dupont
enjeu politique nationale avec
là aussi si l'on s'en réfère aux
résultats des sondages que l'on voit
dans la presse tous les jours un front
national qui serait donné largement
vainqueur de ces élections avec plus de
30 %
christelle le chevalier c'est la
première fois que le fn réussit à mettre
des candidats pour ces élections qui
étaient autrefois ces élections des
cantonales aujourd'hui départementale
dans tous les cantons
quel est votre objectif dans le calvados
à mes premiers objectifs et la
sauvegarde justement de notre
département
les intercommunalités
ça regroupe bien trop grand nombre de
communes et c'est déjà l'heure actuelle
il ya beaucoup de difficultés à gérer
ces intercommunalités
quel est votre objectif de résultat
demain est ce que demain vous pensez
avoir des élus au conseil général du
calvados pour la première fois je n'ai
pas de boule de cristal personne n'a
nous ne savons pas exactement ce que les
électeurs décideront de mars
réponse à de cédric nouvelot pour l'ump
l'objectif de ces élections c'est
effectivement de répondre déjà aux
besoins et aux attentes de la population
effectivement avec le redécoupage et
l'incompréhension delà de la réforme
territoriale qui a été fait comme l'a
dit jean léonce dupont sans aucun sauf
qu'un but recul logique on se retrouve
effectivement avec un électorat qui
perdu qui comprend plus rien il faut
quand vous voyez les gens en porte à
porte
vous allez voir au quotidien c'est ce
qu'ils vous disent ils ont raison donc
il faut remettre de la proximité il faut
remettre de l'efficacité il faut
réexpliquer les enjeux locaux et qu'on
doit avant tout répondre à leurs besoins
et leurs attentes
c'est comme ça qu'on remobilisera c'est
comme ça qu'on leur donnera la confiance
en expliquant qu'on est conscient au
quotidien des enjeux des difficultés
peuvent avoir les professions les
retraités qui sont taxés de plus en plus
les artisans qui ont bien du mal à faire
tourner la roue leurs boutiques
c'est comme ça qu'on va effectivement
réexpliqué qui est un vrai enjeu et
qu'on peut être à leurs côtés qu'on peut
les soutenir c'est comme ça qu'on
remobilisera fait-il aussi pour vous un
enjeu national
il ya effectivement il y aura une
analyse qui sera fait au niveau national
mais encore une fois l'enjeu et c'est
tout ce qu'on dit ou ce qu'on explique
dans les rencontres que l'on fait au
quotidien c'est d'expliquer quand je la
vends tout local quand on regarde les
compétences du département vous avez les
compétences qui sont locales qui ont
attrait quotidien la population et c'est
à ce quotidien qu'il faut répondre il
faut vraiment être conscient des
difficultés que vivent les habitants et
quand vous les rencontrez il vous parle
pas du score de tel ou tel parti
politique
ils vous expliquent ils vous expliquent
ils sont expliqué moi c'est pourquoi est
ce que quand on lit les enquêtes
d'opinion 2
ces gens qui sont interrogés qui
répondent aux clamé hier au cices a
laissé d'aller discuter avec des gens
chez eux discutent avec eux quand vous
discutez avec lui encore une fois ne
vous ne parle pas des scores des partis
politiques c'est pas ce qui les
intéresse et vous passez nationale qui
les intéressent non ce qui est une
histoire de journaliste je dis pas ça me
dis simplement que vous rencontrez des
aînés vous dit s'ils ont des
problématiques pour trouver des deux
missiles quand vous rencontrez des
artisans vous expliquent qu'ils sont en
ce moment sous le coup du rsi quand vous
rencontrez les principaux de collèges
ils peuvent vous parler de leurs
difficultés qui vas voir c'est tous ces
sujets qui importe au fond c'est c'est
pas c'est pas de savoir quel sera le
score de tel ou tel parti politique
l'orne le président a dit tout à l'heure
l'intérêt c'est de savoir quelles sont
les hommes et les femmes qu'on veut
envoyer effectivement que c'est
départementale pour répondre à ses
besoins
alors on va encore dire quelques mots
des enjeux politiques alors dans le
département mais aussi on a commencé à
l'évoquer au niveau national parce que
certains partis notamment l'ump veulent
nationaliser cette campagne la gauche
elle part divisée dans ces élections le
front de gauche sera présent dans une
vingtaine de cantons dans le calvados le
front de gauche dont la priorité est la
politique sociale le front de gauche
seul contre tous
c'est la question qu'on a posés à
marie-laure herbes ou c'est une des
responsables du front de gauche pour ces
cantonales dans le calvados
on l'écouté je ne suis pas sûr que les
gens se reconnaissent enfin
reconnaissent dans le gouvernement
la gauche donc ça c'est un vrai problème
pour le front de gauche est ouvertement
contre la politique du gouvernement dans
cette campagne à ça absolument en tout
cas contre la politique d'austérité
ça c'est sûr contre le ps pas contre le
ps contre la politique mise en place par
le gouvernement qui est une politique
d'austérité qui est une politique qui
dans le département les gens dit les
élus disent ah on n'a pas les moyens
pour assurer
toutes les compétences du département et
au niveau national
il va pour toutes les politiques
austérité second tour est ce que vous
appellerez à voter pour le candidat du
parti socialiste
s'il est en mesure de se maintenir alors
à un candidat ump ou front national pour
le serez vous que direz-vous pour le
second tour d'abord nous ce qui est très
important c'est bien entendu de faire
barrage au fn
ça c'est évident bon deuxièmement nous
ne souhaitons pas que la droite reprenne
le département comme c'est le cas
actuellement
ceci étant dit nous nous attendons le
soir des résultats pour prendre nos
décisions et pour consulter un certain
nombre de gens parce que nous on va pas
s'engager comme ça mais oui non voilà un
goût du front de gauche qui ne donne pas
de consigne de vote pour l'instant pour
le second tour mais on a bien compris
qu'elle était contre le fn contre une
droite qui conserverait le département
du calvados message que vous avez
entendu j'en ans du pont et contre une
adhésion systématique au programme du
parti socialiste
clotilde valter justement qu'avez-vous à
lui répondre qu'est ce que j'ai à lui
répondre qu'il faut quand on prend les
responsabilités qu'on est élu sur un
mandat local comme je l'étais comme
conseillère générale et je suis encore
jusqu'à la fin du mois comme je le suis
comme comme des puis comme député de la
majorité
quand on prend des responsabilités on
est on se confronte à la réalité et la
gauche elle existe d'accord mais l
exclusion et par madame je pense pas que
ça intéresse beaucoup les électeurs les
électeurs sont sûres comme l'a dit
cédric nouvelot comme je l' ai dit tout
à l'heure il faut qu'on leur parle et
qu'on leur parle de leur sujet concret
et venir dans quelques années concret au
quotidien c'est ça vous m'avez demandé
rec te répondre sur la question de
l'austérité je réponds que lorsqu'on est
à la tête d'une collectivité
lorsqu'on est parlementaire
on connaît les problèmes des finances
publiques que ce soit prêt en local que
ce soit au plan national on sait ce que
ça veut dire d'augmenter les impôts et
donc on évite de tenir des propos qui
soit aussi rapide
étonnant étant un petit peu se sont
rendus dans l'atmosphère bas je le dis
je c'est pour ça que je serai pas là
dessus
question de guillaume ballard de ouest
france monsieur jolie notamment les
écologistes participent à cette division
de la gauche parce que je crois que
hormis dans sept cantons où il ya un
semblant d'union dans le calvados
comment vous partez en ordre dispersé
est-ce que vous avez tous bien étudié le
nouveau mode de scrutin est ce que avec
la très faible participation attendue
cette division finalement ne voit pas d
boulevard à l'extrême aura alors je vais
d'abord vous répondre en parlant de
l'abstention parce qu'en fait
l'abstention pour moi c'est la
problématique de cette élection et c'est
la faute des politiques pas de la
politique et on voit bien qu'il ya une
manifestation autour de charlie on
arrive à mobiliser des manifestations il
ya autant de monde selon la police que
sont les organisateurs d'ailleurs donc
c'est vraiment pas un rejet de la
politique nous c'est à nous politiques
de savoir pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
intéresser des gens et francis joly on
t'envoie le député sociale et de
l'oracle écologistes pardon de loire
atlantique françois de rugy qui dit
mettons des amendes rendre le vote
obligatoire et une amende pour ceux qui
ne vont pas voter
est ce que pour vous c'est une bonne
idée alors pour moi c'est pas une bonne
idée parce que on va passer à la conte
entre et c'est plutôt ce pour moi la
force et la conviction et c'est à nous
d'aller chercher tous les électeurs y
compris ceux du fn est vraiment tous les
électeurs et les abstentionnistes en
leur présentant des nouveaux projets on
est un peu en france dans une
philosophie du xxème siècle ont encore
des notables qui décide
il faut qu'on change il faut qu'on passe
à petit concrète à petit du quotidien et
c'est ce qu'on a essayé de faire à caen
et c'est pour ça que j'ai donc répondre
à votre question maintenant à quand donc
on a choisi sur les cinq cantons de
faire une liste d'autonomie puisqu'en
fait c'est un rassemblement europe
ecologie les verts et citoyen et ses dix
citoyens qui pratiquent l'écologie au
quotidien
l'avantagé l'écologie c'est qu'on peut
la pratiquer au quotidien peut mettre en
actes ses propos tout le temps et du
coup on veut laisser le choix aux
électeurs de se positionner sur cette
écologie est en fait les élections
en france on est quand même autour du
bipartisme depuis toujours à part les
européennes
les régionales où c'est la vraie
proportionnelle sinon le premier tour
c'est choisir
c'est pour ça qu'il faut y aller aussi
est le deuxième tour ben je dois choisir
en fonction des programmes et des
différents je le disais au début de
l'émission entre les candidats on va
parler des enjeux de ces élections sur
maintenant les thématiques fortes sur la
politique du département
d'abord une question c'est quel rôle
jouera le département du calvados demain
à partir du 1er janvier 2016 pour cette
grande normandie
on sait que ça sera un changement
considérable 1 pas seulement
géographique mais dans les
collaborations entre les départements
jean léonce dupont vous avez déclaré kan
et le calvados sont en danger
si rouen est choisie comme capitale
ça fait beaucoup parler dans la presse
est ce que ce n'est pas un combat perdu
d'avancé si vous le dit comme ça non pas
du tout alors d'abord vous ne faites par
les la région c'est un beau sujet c'est
effectivement un des éléments de
l'élection mais je rappelle quand même
c'est des gens qui vont gérer
l'assemblée les problèmes quotidiens
l'ensemble de la population et qui vont
représenter le territoire mais vous avez
raison il ya une dimension quand même de
la réorganisation de la région il faut
que vous sachiez que je pense
sincèrement je le dis ça peut déplaire
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les rouennais
ont une attitude un peu arrogante
c'est un peu du genre je prends tout et
les autres se débrouilleront avec le
reste alors je veux le siège du conseil
régional
je veux le siège de la préfecture je
veux le rassemblement des services de
l'état avec tout ce que cela entraîne
y compris en milliers d'emplois y
compris en enfants dans les écoles et
donc eh bien vous verrez avec le reste
sachant que je suis métropole que je
suis sur l' axe naturel de développement
de la normandie puisque je suis sur
l'axé seine et donc pour en avoir une
idée tout à fait consciente et bien vous
avez les éléments à la signature du
contrat de plan état région
quand le premier ministre est venu en
fleur et qu'elle rejoindra le calvados
aujourd'hui elle qu'elle d'ange sur le
même train de plans signés par la
basse-normandie 379 euros par habitant
en haute normandie
551 euros et sur le contrat de plan
inter régionale j'ose espérer qu'il ne
préfigure pas l'avenir
90% des sommes engagées seront engagés
sur la haute-normandie
vous comprenez pourquoi il faut pas du
tout partir défaitiste mais il faut
partir avec une volonté effectivement de
ce bain de se battre pour faire en sorte
que la réunification demain ça ne soit
pas une fusion absorption ça soit un
regroupement où on est de part et
d'autre de la scène gagnant gagnant la
terre pour le parti socialiste
justement quand vous entendez jean
léonce dupont dire il faut défendre les
intérêts des calvadosiens de la ville de
caen vous êtes prononcer clairement
derrière la candidature de nicolas
rossignol a du reste et je pense que je
voudrais que pas tout mélanger
je pense que on a un problème déjà en
basse normandie
c'est que le calvados ne joue pas son
rôle de moteur c'est le département le
plus peuplé
c'est le département qui pourrait
coordonner et porter le territoire et
porter le calvados en basse-normandie et
on a trois présidents de conseils
généraux qui sont du même bord politique
je crois pas me tromper et qui
travaillent trop peu ensemble qu'ils
n'ont pas d'affirmation et de travail
collectif et j'aimerais qu'il soit
d'accord plus souvent sur les dossiers
vont rentrer en suisse par exemple
l'unification à celui des forces
agissant de la s'agissant de la grande
normandie la grande normandie à nous de
prendre notre place est à nous de la
défendre et là aussi nicolas sarkozy
avait il ya quelques années annoncé la
fusion par décret des deux régions
ça a été panique à droite parce qu'on
n'avait rien préparé on ne savait pas
comment on allait faire et moi j'ai pas
entendu de projets portés sur le fond en
tout état de cause c'est la gauche qui a
voté cette réunification et maintenant
effectivement nous allons développer ce
que nous voulons en faire pour revenir
au calvados et à caen moi je ne voudrais
pas retrouver dans cette norme grande
normandie les débats permanents et
l'opposition permanente qu'on a au
conseil général entre caen et le
territoire parce que c'est insupportable
nous sommes tous sur le même sur un même
territoire et c'est tous ensemble que
nous serons forts est meilleure et sur
ce territoire de la grande normandie il
faut que chacun trouve sa place
il faut construire quelque chose d
qui libre et entre caen rouen sert
boulevard toutes les villes et tous les
territoires question qu'il faut savoir
si caen et le calvados parce que encore
une fois si vous êtes élu demain vous
serez appelés à défendre les intérêts
des habitants du calvados dans des
politiques départementales et dans une
grande région encore une fois ça va être
un des évènements des prochains mois est
ce que oui ou non les calvadosiens et
des cannes et sont en danger de jouer je
vais m'adresser à cédric nouvelot pour
l'ump et à christelle le chevalier pour
le front national il faut effectivement
il n'ya pas rond ne ressort pas comme
une métropole la dimension européenne
naturel donc ça veut dire qu'un vrai
débat et qu'il faut articuler plutôt les
complémentarités entre les différentes
villes que l'on peut avoir quand a toute
sa place et laura toussaint passe on se
battra pour en tout cas
il faut surtout garder à caen et
renforcer son pôle métropolitain avec
tout ce qui est la recherche ce qui est
l'enseignement tout ce qui va être le
domaine économique mais elle n'y a pas
de regret mais fionie stratis que vous
ferez regarder les forces vives sur le
territoire et c'est ça qu'il faut faire
est-ce que vous très concrètement oui ou
non est ce que vous partagez la vie de
jean léonce dupont qui dit il faut que
quand soit capitale au moment des choix
est ce que vous dit la même chose on dit
qu'il faut que quand garde son rôle
moteur clé capitale comme elle est en ce
moment et qu'on évidemment veux pas que
ce soir auront qu'ils puissent se tirer
l'ensemble tout ce qui est économique
tout ce qu'ils recherchent formation le
chu par exemple sont les vrais enjeux
sur lesquels on se battra et puis il
faut aussi garder la proximité parce que
la vraie problématique aussi dans la
réunification ce qu'il faut faire
attention et ça va être important au
niveau du conseil départemental c'est
que les conseillers départementaux garde
cette proximité gardent le lien de
proximité qu'est décision ne parte pas
et qu'ils m'ont témoignée pas de la
population on va refermer le chapitre
mais simplement j'aimerais entendre vos
avis si le joli geste est le chevalier g
manière très très content mais très très
bien où je crois que le débat la
capitale politique
il doit avoir lieu mais c'est pas
forcément important washington new york
on sait pas c'est pas on a ces
exemples-là pour moi l'enjeu c'est se
battre sur l'université c'est se battent
sur le chu il ya deux chu dans cette
région y en a un rang à caen je pense
pas que le gouvernement va faire le
choix de financer deux chu donc il faut
vraiment qu'on garde ses compétences en
sciences en sciences on a les yeux
geo fait nom de gilles eric séralini on
a des atouts et c'est à nous de matisse
atouts en avant si on met ses atouts en
main avant on peut gagner ce rôle de
capitale universitaire donc quand vous
regardez un plan sans que cela soit
qu'en or on a bien compris c'est pas
essentiel c'est pas c'est pas ce qui va
défoncer je pense que sanofi est
intéressante parce qu'elle consiste à
renforcer ce qui fait l'identité de caen
ce qui fait l'identité de notre
territoire
et c'est à travers cela qu'on trouvera
toute notre place dans la grande
normandie moi je partage assez cette
analyse est naturel et où ce monsieur
fabius est effectivement dans le parti
on l'a vécue notamment au moment de la
chambre de la cour régionale des comptes
je rappelle que la cour de régionale des
comptes bas normande avait un plus grand
nombre de collectivités autour d'elle et
qu'elle était beaucoup plus central et
comme par hasard elle a été regroupée
effectivement avant tout la nécessité
nous et d'être actif d'attractif et
volontaire sur l'ensemble des dossiers
et sam usher il referme ça parce que ça
sera des barrages en syrie c'est un
phénomène émergent à moi mais on voulait
évoquer sur la place de caen et du
calvados
puisque ça ait fait l'objet de quelques
échanges entre vous candidat et avec
cette déclaration du président du
conseil général sortant jean léonce
dupont
on voulait l'évoqué juste question quand
auront oui nous ne sommes pas encore
dans la réunification que déjà vous
voyez c'est la bataille entre caen et
roy peut-être ya t-il quand même un
moyen une possibilité a trouvé pour que
nous puissions travailler ensemble tout
simplement voilà d'accord on va parler
d'emploi département du calvados a vu
une progression du nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi de 2% l'espace d'un an il y a
trente trois mille chômeurs dans le
calvados
il ya aussi plus de 15000 personnes qui
touchent le rsa le revenu de solidarité
active financé par le département le
nombre de bénéficiaires explose 150 en
plus chaque mois dans le calvados 40%
c'est important 40% au moins de 35 ans
que leur dites-vous
clotilde valter ce que je leur dis c'est
que j'aurai revenir aux compétences du
département parce qu on est là pour
parler des
en départemental et la solidarité évolué
au coeur mais là aussi pour parler au
genre est bien au coeur des compétences
des compétences du conseil général et je
crois que ça doit être le marqueur
ça doit être le marqueur la solidarité
avec une double solidarité d'ailleurs
une solidarité à l'égard des personnes
et des personnes en difficultés des
personnes âgées des personnes des
personnes handicapées mais aussi la
solidarité des territoires j'espère
qu'on lit qu'on y reviendra première
solidarité ça c'est que chacun déjà et
un emploi c'est aussi ça on va pas
mélanger je veux bien content que
l'assistanat comme ces jeunes ont pu
arriver alors soit on a un débat de
politique nationale et on y va
qu'avez vous fait quel est le bilan de
la droite au gouvernement entre 2002 et
2012 et non mais moi je parle du
département je pense qu'on s'adresse aux
citoyens
six ans elle sort mais ça fait dans
l'apaisement qui sont sans emploi
s'adressent aux cars 2 le jeune sur mon
canton qui sont au chômage depuis
thiriez qui n'a pas à les violer une vie
j'ai plus proche de la normandie
arrêtez de l'année les maillots jesus a
conféré de julin si vous le permettez ça
ne se voyait pas la parole quelques
quelques instants vous avez tous eu
l'occasion d'être au pouvoir et de mener
des actions positives
quel est le bilan que vous pouvez en
tirer aujourd'hui enfin ps ump yves
maillard et remettre le débat donc
effectivement les compétences
départementales comédie mad about her
les compétences départementales la
gestion des personnes âgées
l'ablation du handicap et là je veux
dire c'est un nid emploi on peut
effectivement faire de l'emploi de
qualité de proximité
donc non délocalisables puisqu'on va pas
délocaliser nos personnes âgées j'espère
pas en tout cas
donc là on a quelque chose à faire là
dessus avec la compétence qui impose aux
départements de gérer justement la
solidarité et par cette solidarité entre
faire beaucoup de choses je vais
reprendre le chiffre qui est important
c'est 150 bénéficiaires du rsa en plus
chaque mois rien que dans le département
du calvados
selon un sondage paru cette semaine 80 %
des jeunes de moins de 25 ans se disent
pessimistes par rapport à l'emploi et 6
sur 10 se disent prêts à quitter la
france comment fait-on pour les garder
dans votre département puisque vous
aurez à mener cette politique pour le
calvados
quelles propositions faites-vous qu'elle
solutions avez-vous pour conserver ses
jeunes pour qu'ils vivent et travaillent
dans notre département
jean léonce dupont franck c'est une très
belle question c'est une question
importante à reposer ça a été dit tout
le monde est concerné je voudrais
simplement vous dire qu'aujourd'hui nous
ne savons pas si les départements vont
garder le peu de la compétence
développement économique qu'elles ont
donc si on pouvait effectivement revenir
sur la problématique du rsa vous avez
raison 150 bénéficiaires supplémentaires
tous les mois
c'est en un an une dépense nouvelle de 8
millions d'euros et la question qu'il
faut poser en réalité est que nous
aurons tous à régler si nous siégeons
demain c'est bien de savoir comment nous
allons avoir capacité à répondre à cette
demande des personnes qui sont dans la
difficulté des aides de l'état pour le
fait en l'espace de dix ans rien que sur
le rsa le solde à payer par le
département
c'était donc donc dire déduit des
financements de l'état il ya dix ans
nous avions un reste à charge de 3
millions d'euros cette année 33 millions
d'euros
donc vous voyez un déficit absolument
considérable à la charge du département
nous sommes sur une solidarité nationale
payés essentiellement par le local et
vous détruit la ville et l'attrait pas
d'aujourd'hui il est jeune et a dit que
c'était nouveau madame r je dis
simplement que les choses ne s'arrangent
pas et ne s'arrange pas vous l'imaginez
bien parce que quand l'économie va pas
bien quand il ya notamment des problèmes
d'emploi et bien vous avez moins de
rentrées fiscales notamment
et c'est le moment où les besoins de
solidarité sont effectivement les plus
importants est ce que dans leur match à
risque oui m challier des départements
de la collectivité départementale le cas
la dose comme les autres départements
est un vrai sujet est un vrai enjeu
national
j'en arrive après des années à la
conclusion qu'il nous faut revoir le
financement et la répartition des impôts
nationaux de ce pays au niveau local est
ce que demain il y a un réservoir
huissier pour ce billet absolue grand si
le contexte devait perdurer
je pense que d'ici cinq ans un certain
nombre de départements n'auront plus les
moyens de payer
vous savez pour rebondir sur la barre
vous avez des départements aujourd'hui
en région parisienne la charge
par habitant est de l'ordre de 80 euros
et puis dans certains départements de
montagne où la population est totalement
vieillissante
vous êtes à 400 euros de charges par
habitant comment voulez-vous
effectivement que ces départements
tiennent dans la durée vu la pyramide
démographique il faut donc prendre un
certain nombre de décisions qui sont des
décisions d'ordre national alors vous
avez pris une décision puisque vous
évoquez le manque de moyens des
départements gens n'osent dupont il ya
quelques mois vous avez décidé de ne
plus appliquer la circulaire taubira qui
vous obliger à aider les mineurs
étrangers
est-ce que ça n'est pas une décision
purement politique et symbolique
non nous appliquons la circulaire tombe
bien la circulaire taubira jeu
l'expliquent c'est le fait que des
mineurs étrangers de la région
parisienne soit répartie sur les
départements on va dire de province
c'est une mesure qui aujourd'hui cette
année me coûte 2 millions d'euros sur
des problèmes d'équipement qui font
qu'une partie des besoins que nous avons
pour notre population propre et bien
nous avons défini des difficultés à les
traiter
donc j'ai alerté en disant nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à augmenter le
nombre de personnes que nous allons
recevoir ne serait ce que par le nombre
d'équipements ne serait-ce qu pas
l'exécution purement excuse moi c'est
symbolique
on parle d'une centaine de cas une
centaine de jeunes pour le département
oui ça nous coûte ça nous coûte cette
année 2015 2 millions d'euros je vous
assure ça n'est pas symbolique c'est une
vraie valeur propre parti socialiste
jean léonce dupont a annoncé ça
effectivement il ya quel cette décision
il ya quelques mois en disant qu'il
n'ait pu le faire sauf que un de ses
collègues dans un autre département de
france a pris effectivement la décision
puisqu'il a signé il a cité la décision
qu'il a et qui a été portée au tribunal
administratif et il est effectivement
été sa décision a été annulée par le
tribunal administratif grave d'être revu
oui oui mais je pense que c'est à ce
moment là que jean léonce dupont ont
fait citer s'étaient exprimés et donc je
pense qu'effectivement c'est très
marginal et je pense que quand vous
demandez à nos concitoyens
les mineurs isolés en
lucky femmes se sont déjà joints des
mineurs qui n'ont pas de moyen de s'en
sortir de vivre seul on sait très bien
que le conseil général a la
responsabilité et de la solidarité
j'arrive à dos je crois que c'était dans
l'air du temps à ce moment là de lancer
ça monsieur le président je m'en
excuserai match accroché
alors chacun son tour exemple personnel
francis joly pour que l'office accueille
dans sa classe un élève qui vient de
roumanie à un mineur isolé et je veux
dire c'est une richesse pour toute la
classe pour les parents d'accueillir ce
genre ce genre de personne à ses fans je
suis en train de mal m'exprimer mais
c'est vraiment une richesse d'accueillir
ces enfants et ces hanoune une sono la
richesse du calvados sépare ça qu'on
sera grand aussi il faut financer ça ça
doit être une priorité mais soyons
clairs nous recevons en direct un
certain nombre de mineurs étrangers
nous les accueillons le problème là
c'est la répartition de ceux qui
arrivent en région parisienne c'est un
soin soyons extrêmement clair on va
avancer dans cette émission je me sens
la place de richard opposait juste un
sujet le céderaient sociaux sur la
partie en ump
quant aux blazers inculte et de
financement du rsa je le redis si nous
ne relançons pas l'emploi si nous ne
soutenons pas l'emploi local et les
structures économiques locales que l'on
a chez nous on a des forces artisanale
agriculture ostréiculture les commerces
on a des vrais force si on ne les
soutient pas effectivement on se
retrouve avec des chômeurs et qu'il faut
derrière assisté ça va avec
l'augmentation des charges sociales
mais si on peut effectivement les
soutenir entre contraintes
administratives matraquage fiscal
quand vous allez effectivement dans les
communes vous avez des déréglementations
qui tombent de plus en plus et qui
empêche le développement économique dont
qui crée du chômage il faut d'abord
soutenir ces structures
effectivement il ya des choix à faire de
temps en temps parce qu'on ne pourra pas
tout financer
alors la semaine dernière pour faire
avancer le débat essayé d'évoquer
d'autres questions on a vu cette
manifestation des aides à domicile
c'était au pied du pont de normandie
elles étaient environ 300 venus de toute
la normandie pour dénoncer une baisse
des financements publics la prise en
charge des personnes âgées
c'est une des compétences du département
par le biais notamment de la pale
personnalisée d'autonomie un chiffre
simplement qui illustre le
vieillissement de la population on
comptera plus de soixante sept mille
personnes de plus de 75 ans dans le
calvados
soit 10 % la population d'ici la fin de
l'année qu'est ce qu'on fait comment on
prend en charge cette population
vieillissante
est ce que l'on construit de nouvelles
places en maisons de retraite en ehpad
est-ce qu'on renforce les aides à
domicile
je vais écouter tel le chevalier pour le
front national qui s'est pas exprimé
depuis quelques minutes
je pense qu'effectivement il faut aider
l'aide au maintien à domicile
déjà dans un premier temps ensuite
revoir les aides lorsque les personnes
âgées sont vraiment trop dépendants qui
est qu'elles doivent être accueillis
dans les temps des structures adéquates
puisque bien entendu leurs pensions bien
évidemment dans bon nombre de cas ne
suffit pas et c'est un désastre
aujourd'hui mais est ce qu'on donne plus
d'argent justement pour ces aides à
domicile qui réclament davantage de
moyens on leur dit qu'il faut aller plus
vite d'après les témoignages qu'on a pu
recueillir lors de cette manifestation
elles nous disent on nous demande de
rester une demi heure avec ces personnes
âgées dans le cadre
du soutien à qu'elle leur offre alors
qu'il ya un besoin d'une heure et demie
toujours plus toujours plus vite avec
moins d'argent
cédric nouvelot que leur répondez vous
c'est un vrai souci humain est
effectivement la partie aide à domicile
est à la fois une source d'emplois comme
ça effectivement été dit l'heure et
c'est aussi un besoin qu'à la population
quand vous rencontrez effectivement les
aînés dans leur maison ou vendre chez
eux vous expliquent ils ont du mal à
trouver des missiles or pourquoi parce
que ce sont souvent des emplois à temps
partiel ce sont souvent des emplois dont
la valorisation est compliquée et quand
vous regardez moi j'ai sur le canton de
console j'ai à douvrin un lycée qui
forment qu à une session de formation il
ne remplit pas cette section de
formation parce que encore une fois on a
du mal à rendre cette formation
attractive on a du mal à rendre le
métier attractif donc il va bien falloir
valoriser ces formations valoriser cet
emploi si on veut trouver des à domicile
et puis répondre aux besoins qu'on peut
avoir dans nos mémoires et commencer
joly pour europe écologie c'est une
évidence mais quand mes parents avaient
20 ans il avait déjà perdu leurs parents
moi j'ai 46 ans j'ai la chance que mes
enfants et leurs quatre grands parents
donc c'est quand même une chance vous
quand même remettre ça en avant mais
attends je crois qu'il faut qu'on ait de
l'imagination on en parle des pannes on
parle de choses comme ça et si on
essayait plus offert de micro structures
pour accueillir ces personnes âgées des
regrouper et ça peut être également ce
qu'on appelle les papy loft à
l'allemande ou on met ensemble des
étudiants papy loft ou simplement par
l'api loft c'est finalement manière
imagée on garde les
regarde tout le monde sur son territoire
les personnes âgées ne veulent pas non
plus des ménages est chez elle en
regardant les quartiers mais par contre
vont occuper par exemple le rez de
chaussée et des étudiants va tout en
haut elles vont avoir vraiment un lien
de proximité et avec ça en plus on va
répondre aussi la question de la
solitude parce que là on en train de
parler ménages en train de parler de
choses comme ça mais aussi la question
de solitude qui s'était posé pendant les
jeux ces facteurs non mais rappelez-vous
la canicule
monsieur vous vous rappelez vous la
canicule problème la canicule le
changement climatique nous en amener
d'autres on n'aura pas le choix
comment on fait pour répondre à ça eh
bien peut-être aussi en ayant
l'imagination en trouvant de nouvelles
solutions et pas c'est dire si la
question de moyens finalement les
maisons de retraite
aujourd'hui on en est où est-ce qu'elle
déplace pour tout le monde c'est une
question de coût également aussi pour
les personnes âgées
est ce que demain tout le monde va
trouver une place quand il ya besoin en
maison de retraite qu'on ne veut pas
être maintenue à 2600 euros et pour quel
1600 euros la place on n'est pas des 800
euros de retraite moyenne
alors alors question de philippe van
leeuw s'ils vont me faire produire la
canicule
je trouve à dire que l'année de la
canicule il y avait eu moins de décès
dans le département du calvados que les
autres années ce qui montre bien que
c'est un département où il fait bon
vivre et où il fait aussi bondir de plus
beaucoup et où nous avons est né et où
nehari naturellement un climat qui est
favorable mais nous avons surtout une
structure humaine qui fait que la
proximité des uns et des autres ont
évité un certain nombre de grandes
difficultés
philippe de la soul et modestement
simplement savoir si on crée de
nouvelles s'il a bien fait raison mais
sait déjà c'est déjà en route
nous avons déjà je le dis notamment en
tant que résident de de calvados habitat
nous avons déjà réalisé ici et là un
certain nombre de structures où se
trouve exactement ce que vous avez dit
c'est-à-dire proximité c'est à dire
effectivement assistance d'un certain
nombre de personnes
animations à l'intérieur du quartier ce
qu'il faut savoir également c'est que le
souhait de la population
c'est de rester fondamentalement le plus
longtemps possible à domicile
savez-vous qu'en quelques années on
rentrait dans les maisons de retraite il
ya il ya de nombreuses années en avait
65 ans on est passé à 70 on est passé à
75 80 aujourd'hui la moyenne d'âge de
rentrer dans les établissements c'est de
l'ordre de 84 ans d'où l'importance de
l'ensemble des emplois effectivement à
domicile pour aider la personne âgée à
rester dans le lieu de
qui est le sien qu'elle a choisi dans
les maisons de retraite est ce qu'il ya
assez de place aujourd'hui ce qu'il y en
aura assez de mains est liée à la
question du coût
il ya évidemment la question du coup
c'est naturellement d'ailleurs pour ça
que lorsque les familles ne sont pas en
état de payer c'est bien le département
qui prend en charge et donc l'évolution
de la démographie pose problème
notamment parce que nous avons notre
population calvadosienne qui vieillit
mais parce que comme le calvados et
attractif il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui viennent
vieillir dans le département du calvados
et quand une personne est là depuis
trois mois c'est le département
d'accueil qui doit effectivement prendre
en charge la montée de la dépendance
dont contre au travail ailleurs on passe
sa vie ailleurs et puis on prend sa
retraite
finir sa vie donc elle serait mieux
compris dans le calvados avec les
problèmes que ça peut engendrer cédric
nouvelot pour la problématique aussi du
financement des domiciles des structures
c'est aussi la problématique des
retraites
effectivement quand en ce moment vous
avez des taxations sans précédent sur
les retraites sauf une régime standard
ou sur les régimes complémentaires
effectivement ça pose souci ça pose
soucis à ses aînés pour se financer ou
des établissements où se financer de
l'aide
et là effectivement il ya un vrai enjeu
qui est à l'enjeu à soutenir qu'il
enjeux au niveau national qu'il faudra
régler on peut pas continuer à taxer
comme on le fait les retraites et en
particulier petites retraites imposons
le court on sort de la politique du
département
non mais je je vais répondre sur la
politique du département justement parce
que en parler des compétences je parle
j'ai commencé tout à l'heure à dire que
la compétence sociale était au coeur des
compétences du département et que
justement le jean léonce dupont disait
je me demande ce que ce qui se fait
avoir comme compétence le développement
économique et tout le reste je pense que
justement la question du conseil général
à un moment où la solidarité est au
coeur de ses compétences au moment où
ces dépenses de solidarité augmente
c'est justement de cesser de
s'éparpiller sur un certain nombre de
dépenses en dehors du champ de
compétences du conseil général comme
justement l'action économique qui
appartient à la région qui doit être
aussi anc est prise en charge par les
communautés de communes et par l'état il
n'y a pas besoin de 36 niveaux
d'intervention et je pense que au lieu
de sabrer dans les dépenses pour les
personnes âgées ou pour les personnes
handicapées comme vous l'avait fait lors
du but
et 2014 eh bien il eût mieux valu
conserver ses moyens pour les personnes
en difficulté et vous départir de zaire
certaines interventions publiques qui
sont traités mieux ailleurs et dont
c'est la compétence ailleurs alors
repenser comment lors du pont et on va
essayer de faire assez court pour
pouvoir poser d'autres questions nous
n'avons évidemment pas du tout ça braie
nous avons simplement diminué l'extra
légales c'est-à-dire le plus que ce
qu'exigeait la loi que nous faisions à
une époque nous avions des ressources
madame d'alter manama terre quand même
est assez extraordinaire
nous avons des dotations de l'état qui
diminue de façon considérable - 15
millions cette année
il faut bien trouver un certain nombre
de sujets sur lesquels on peut
effectivement le faire mais surtout
c'est une fausse bonne idée que vient de
dire madame haltères pour une raison
simple c'est que si nous n'avions que le
champ du social quand vous avez des
augmentations de 8 millions d'euros en
une seule année
rien que sur le rsa si vous n'aviez pas
d'autres départements de compétences sur
lequel à un moment donné parce qu'il ya
un pic
vous êtes en capacité de rééquilibrer et
bien vous seriez effectifs indique
cettex 40 étant extrêmement rapidement
en état de cessation de la mort
donc il faut des champs de compétence
assez large pour pas avoir capacité à
vous voulez c'est sûr que c'est une vous
étiez pas pour la limitation de mauvais
temps pour ce sujet si vous voulez bien
sur les économies que fait le
département ont été un sujet qui a
défrayé la chronique lors des dernières
semaines c'est la question de savoir si
on peut conserver toutes les casernes de
pompiers ça fait l'objet d'un débat
ses casernes pour financer par le
département le nouveau schéma des
secours et les communes et les communes
40 % pour le département absolument le
nouveau schéma d'aidés secours présenté
le 30 janvier dernier prévoit la
fermeture de six casernes trois autres
seraient menacés la question c'est est
ce que l'on garde ses casernes qui font
parfois mois d'une centaine
d'interventions par an on va répartir
les temps de parole là aussi cédric
nouvelot la sécurité en matière de
sécurité on est d'accord que sur le
département avec la baisse des dotations
et les économies à faire
évidemment le champ de la sécurité doit
rester un enjeu et quand vous êtes en
particulier dans les communes rurales
il faut entendre cette inquiétude il
faut entendre le souci quand on n'est
pas dans les pôles urbains que peut
avoir la population légitimement sur le
maintien des moyens dans les casernes
clairement on vous dit la proposition de
fermer six ou neuf casernes c'est pas la
bonne moi j'ai expliqué sur la caserne
de courseulles qui est sur mon canton
qu'effectivement je souhaitais qu'il
maintient les moyens pour des raisons
simples d'intervention et de sécurité de
mater la sécurité de la population et si
demain cédric nouvelot vous avez demandé
un moratoire de fait vous nous dites on
sait que le préfet a dit qu'il allait
signer en l'état on ne sait pas quand
mais rapidement maintenant ce ce schéma
qu'il ya un vrai point êtes proche
politiquement dans les rues du pont vie
là dessus il ya un vrai point de
discorde entre vous deux il peut y avoir
écouté me suis pas je ne suis pas expert
comme peut l'être jean-léonce sur la
partie financière du conseil général
mais j'entends effectivement les besoins
les attentes de la population en matière
de sécurité
et si un choix qui doit être fait il ya
des choix qui doivent être faits
financièrement clairement la population
désire souhaite demande qu'on puisse
maintenir effectivement caserne quand on
me dit que ceux ci on enlève tel ou tel
moyen l'intervention viendra des autres
casernes
on sait très bien que c'est compliqué
qui est bon pour tout le monde moi
j'avais pris l'exemple du secours
routier effectivement mais qui va
normalement pouvoir être maintenue je
souhaite en tout cas je les demande et
c'est important de défendre des pompiers
d'en demander quand ils ont eu la
crainte que ce secours soit enlevé
pourquoi parce que ils font près de 100
interventions par an
depuis la caserne pour pour ces secours
là effectivement légitimement elles sont
actives et la population autour et et
c'est normal après c'est pas une
divergence fondamentale
il y aura un travail à faire
effectivement c'est revenir juste pour
terminer le schéma aurait pu être
déterminée peut-être différemment et
c'est vrai que j'aurais préféré pour
être père qu'on attende le
renouvellement des instances
départementales alors je sais qu'il
avait déjà été prorogée et qu'on
arrivait à l'échelon maximal position on
va dire compris effectivement que vous
proposez un moratoire sur ce schéma des
secours si demain où poussent le fais
entrer dans la majorité du conseil
départemental et j'en ai ensuite on est
à côté de vous il a compris le message
il n'est pas forcément apparemment tout
à fait d'accord annoncé une solution
mais le message s'est perdu
on va le laisser à part leur histoire
d'abord francis joly europe ecologie les
verts
on vient d'avoir un débat sur
effectivement le place du calvados dans
la normandie l'une des richesses du
calvados qu'on n'a pas évoqué ses son
maillage territorial et son maillage
territorial et les mis à mal depuis un
moment on parle fermetures d'hôpitaux de
tribunaux de choses comme ça de la
maternité j'en parle même pas donc il
faut qu'on garde cette richesse cette
richesse et passe par du service public
accessible partout c'est un coût certes
maintenant on a les moyens de se
financer deux aérogares une caserne qui
fait quarante interventions passées on
est une maternité il faut garder ça sur
territoire c'est la richesse de notre
territoire
sinon on n'aura plus qu'une ville centre
et la glissance qu'une une caserne qui
intervient peut et est ce qu'elle est à
un moment aussi efficace comme pour une
maternité ont fait qui intervient
récupérer la même chose que pour les
maternités les cas vraiment difficile et
délicat là effectivement offrant l'appui
de la caserne centrale
mais il faut regarder cette proximité et
on a les moyens jeudi on a les moyens de
se financer deux petits aéroports qui
servent juste deux hubs
c'est à dire de décoller pour aller à
lyon et prendre d'autres avions ben
voilà on fait des choix en garde car ça
l'écologie est d'accord avec l'ump qu'on
ne ferme pas des casernes on ne ferme
pas de service public globalement au
delà des casernes jean léonce dupont
alors comment expliquer que vous ayez
proposé de fermer six casernes et
trois casernes qui reprennent
l'ancien schéma 10 à 8 ans qui proposait
cinq casernes dont cinq des six vous
voyez que ça n'ait pas pris dans
l'urgence alors j'entends évidemment
tout ce qui est dit en particulier sur
la défense et la proximité du service
public mais j'entends aussi le problème
du message de la sécurité et le problème
et notamment de concilier effectivement
sécurité et efficacité
alors je vais vous donner le cas de la
caserne de landelles et coupigny dans le
canton de saint sever pour que chacun
comprenne quand même les vrais enjeux
nous avons quatre sapeurs pompiers
volontaires
la possibilité de les mobiliser ensemble
on arrive à une moyenne de 1,4 un départ
ces trois hommes donc en réalité qu'est
ce qui se passe
il se passe que ce sont les casernes
voisines qui démarre et qui vient de se
faire compléter par les hommes de la
caserne donc la population croit qu'ils
ont à proximité quelqu'un pour les
défendre en réalité c'est une
réorganisation qui est fait
nombre de départs dans l'année 44 pains
tard semaine si on retire les sorties
pour sortir gay pour eux pour nous de
guêpe
on est à moins de 30 interventions dans
l'année alors quand on est dans un
environnement budgétaire contraint il y
à un moment où il faut prendre des
décisions et oui nous avons proposé à
chaque sapeur pompier volontaire non pas
de l'affecter dans une caserne mais de
choisir par l'humain n'a caserne de
proximité où il va renforcer les
effectifs et donc être plus efficace un
dernier exemple je ne dirai pas le nom
de la commune vous avez une commune dans
ce département
vous avez notamment un véhicule avec une
grande échelle pour immeubles de grande
hauteur
il ya qu un point c'est dans la commune
y'a pas d'immeubles de grande hauteur
donc il ya quand même un moment il ya
quand même un boudoir sur des immeubles
où il faut poser raisonnablement
rationnel rationnellement et prendre un
certain nombre de décisions vous savez
dans l'assemblée de demain nous avons
besoin de personnes des élus compétents
juste parce que les décisions va être
difficile il faut les prendre avec
justesse et justice et efficaces
compétents justes efficaces mais il faut
prendre des décisions parce qu'on ne
peut pas attendre parce que quand le
conseil d'état décidé une application
immédiate du problème des logements des
pompiers eh bien vous ne pouvez pas
attendre six mois vous ne pouvez pas
attendre un an
il faut immédiatement prendre un certain
nombre de décisions décision pour parti
socialiste explosé justement sa
proposition ainsi fermer celle de
chevalier d'abord que clotilde valter
soulager la question du sapeur pompier
et c'est les casernes ferme ton ces six
voire neuf casernes dans le département
du calvados
est-ce qu'on revient sur le le schéma
départemental des secours qui était
présenté en janvier
ce schéma a donné lieu à effectivement
énormément de polimiquer deux
divergences y compris au sein de la
majorité com de com de l'opposition dont
je crois qu'il y avait des soucis
partout si monsieur le président vous
avez une solution réside dans une
session elle a été unanime dans son vote
in fine et après que vous l'ayez réunis
mais il ya eu beaucoup d'observations y
compris à l'intérieur de votre majorité
effectivement je crois que le mais
chaque commune et chaque territoire a eu
sa caserne parce qu'effectivement
c'était les communes qui gérait les
casernes dans le dans le passé et donc
effectivement le pompier la caserne et
quelque chose d'emblématique et
d'important pour le territoire
simplement aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
la question de la sécurité et de la
possibilité pour les forces et pour les
secours d'être là pour intervenir au
moment où il faut il le convient aussi
de ce conflit est le plus vite possible
c'est pour ça que plutôt que de dire il
faut mettre une caserne la une la et je
veux chacun ma caserne je veux chacun la
grande échelle mon camion etc
la question elle se pose différemment
elle se pose en termes de délais
d'intervention sais je suis dans telle
commune et dans combien de temps arrive
le camion et à grande échelle et c'est
ce qu'elle fait
oui mais celle là monsieur le président
cette jeunesse dans votre propre
majorité notamment le conseiller général
devereaux sic et vice président a estimé
qu'il y avait des délais d'intervention
trop long de la même façon brain ville
sur lèze vous avez pris une décision il
ya un délai d'intervention entre de 20
minutes
j'ai souvent ce ce trajet ça me paraît
extrêmement donc je pense
qu'effectivement il vous faudra
retravailler qu'il faut regarder le
délai d'intervention mais franchement
faites le sans dépasser les limites de
vitesse
brain ville sur lèze jusqu'à une caserne
caennaise vous allez voir vous mettrez
pas 20 minutes on va parler je propose
qu'on regarde ça gomme est de lui qu de
la vitesse et des routes dans un instant
simplement que c'est le chevalier sur ce
schéma des secours enfin moi je tiens à
demander avec les chiots jean léonce
dupont ce qu'il compte faire
donc en fermant ses casernes quel autre
alternative il propose et c'est une
réorganisation complète de l'efficacité
effectivement de l'ensemble des casernes
existantes c'est plutôt renforcé des
casernes qui sont deux proximité sur des
temps d'intervention qui sont
extrêmement réduit et c'est au contraire
avoir plus d'hommes pour avoir en
permanence une meilleure réponse parce
que je reprends mon exemple vous
imaginez bien que quand vous n'avez pas
le nombre nécessaire pour le départ
mais qu'est ce qui se passe ce sont bien
les autres casernes et il faut appeler
et réorganiser ce qui prend plus de
temps donc je vous assure c'est une plus
grande efficacité
alors on va aller au route justement on
parlait de vitesse il ya un instant
faut-il aménager quatre kilomètres de
déviation la fameuse déviation de canal
ville qui permettrait de désengorger de
la sortie de l'autoroute a13 en
direction de deauville
c'est un débat aussi de cette campagne
départementale dans le calvados ségolène
royal en tant que ministre de l'écologie
a mis son veto à ce projet de 36
millions d'euros au motif que cette
déviation est bien traverse une zone de
marais où l'on trouve quelques 200
espèces d'oiseaux
le débat est ouvert les uns les autres
est-ce qu'on fait ou pas cet hôte cette
déviation francis joly pour nom 36
millions d'euros
et en plus il ya trois autres pour bp
2015 et à trois autres projets il ya
déviation de cattenom vie
36 millions d'euros la déviation de
bellengreville vimont 26 millions
d'euros et la fameuse le serpent de mer
de la liaison interquartiers nord 11
millions d'euros
ça nous fait 74 millions d'euros sur les
routes et je n'aime pas la consommation
des terres agricoles
la richesse du calvados cesson
d'agriculture et qu'est ce qu'on fait au
lieu de cultiver ont fait du bitume le
bitume c'est pas l'emploi de demain le
bitume c'est encore plus de routes
encore plus de voitures c'est la
périurbanisation c'est de développement
des campagnes sur des terres agricoles
donc non atteints il ya des secteurs
qu'il faut désengorger alors le plan
état région
c'est pas moi c'est un écolo qui dira la
signature de plan état région qui a été
validé par le conseil des parents
générale jeudi au conseil départemental
a remarqué qu'ils avaient déjà
suffisamment de route dans le calvados
d'ailleurs les conseillers généraux ont
tous réagi alors que c'était scandaleux
ben moi j'ai trouvé ça très très bien
donc c'est pas moi qui te dire il ya
suffisamment de route dans le calvados
on arrête d'en construire on les
entretiens ont renforcé gym douce et ont
misé à la mise sur le tourisme à vélo
pourquoi pas en faisant la fameuse dans
le thé du plan vélo on peut pas aller de
honfleur jusque dans la manche en vélo
et paris deauville à vélo ça va être
compliqué quand même parler de ville à
vélo non mais on parler d'emploi alors
le touriste c'est une force
je vous invite à faire la loire à vélo
et quand sera élu offrait un week-end
d'intégration et on ira faire la loire à
vélo et vous verrez les langues des
personnes qui utilisent le vélo pour les
vacances
et combien ça génère dessous et d'emploi
l'emploi l'économie laitière des vélos
aux quatre candidats qui sont là
pourquoi pas mais pour confort j'en ai
vu questions de guillaume tabard de
ouest france ou pourquoi vous opposez
finalement toujours qu'il vélo qui la
route qui le faire et ce qu'on ne peut
pas faire tout en tout ça ensemble et
offre une fille née pour un
développement harmonieux et surtout
économique de nos territoires ont parlé
tout à l'heure de personnes âgées qui
vont passer leur retraite dans le
département où on a également des jeunes
malheureusement dit part du département
pour les trouver du travail ailleurs
il ya également des soins de sécurité
sur la route vous il ya des déroutes
hyper dangereuse en calvados qu'est ce
qu'on fait il faut bien financer
je suis rapidement francis joly pour
laisser les entraîneurs match que je
peux juste répondant disant
qu'effectivement je pose pas le vélo au
reste moi même j'ai un véhicule jeu
l'utilisent
véhicules motorisés pétrole dedans qui
fait le du gaz à effet de serre donc
j'utilise non ce qu'il faut c'est
effectivement modéré il faut faire des
choix et on en est contraint toute façon
on n'a pas le choix
l'écologie c'est aussi ça se faire des
choix et se donnent du sens à ses choix
et donc oui il faut développer d'autres
modes de transport que la voiture la
voiture nous conduit dans le mur
je vous invite aussi à regarder le coût
d'entretien d'une voiture qu'on parlait
tout à l'heure de rsa de précarité eh
bien ces personnes là comment ils font
pour financer l'entretien ou l'achat de
leur voiture le déplacement elles
peuvent pas on va revenir au problème
des routes parce que c'est une des
compétences pour le moment uniquement du
du département sur précisément ce projet
de déviation qui traverserait se marrer
cette déviation de caleme ville les uns
les autres il nous reste 2 minutes 30
d'émissions donc on va essayer d'aller
très vite
kristen le chevalier qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ou pas à cette route
non on la fait pas non non non non c'est
vrai que nous voulons qu'on lui retire
une route je l'expliqué ont fait l'enjeu
c'est d'avant tous deux restent de
répondre aux priorités sur les routes
les plus accidentogènes et il ya un
facteur économique à prendre en compte
on peut effectivement avoir des très
belles prairies mission n'a plus
d'emploi et si les gens sont obligés de
partir du département pour trouver un
emploi c'est un vrai sujet donc il faut
toujours trouver cet équilibre c'est
comme le directeur guy mallard c'est pas
le cas pas de contraintes y ait pas de
contradiction il faut effectivement
trouver le bon équilibre entre tout ça
donc sur la déviation de qu'est la ville
se serait prêt à aller contre le veto
opposé par ségolène royal
oui mais enfin c'est par la première
contrainte environnementale qu'on nous
met au détriment ça m'a amusé de cela
contre près de l'agriculture passe quand
on voit les contraintes
environnementales qui sont mes par les
écologistes
au milieu agricole et qui viennent
empêcher leur développement il ya des
vrais sujets effectivement à développer
une route pour développer l'économie sur
ce cas précis qui a fait débat jean
léonce dupont de la déviation de
canapville je serai dirait concession il
nous reste une minute trente à dire à
monsieur jolie que nous sommes en train
de travailler pour faire en sorte que
deux fleurs à isigny donc à la porte de
la manche nous puissions effectivement
avoir une continuité en vélo alors sur
canal villemin soit ukr madame royal a
enterré le projet scénique original
qu'il avait rappelé avant
mme royal à un nouvel international
qu'il avait reçu nous avions il ya
quelques années un grand ministère de
l'équipement nous avons maintenant un
mystère des chrysanthèmes c'est à dire
qu'on en perd tout l'étranger tous les
projets et c'est une vraie question que
du développement et dans le calvados est
un peu désespérant désespérant nous
avions une première solution qui avait
été le long de la ligne de chemin de fer
qui était la meilleure on nous a dit à
l'époque non en fait un autre projet on
a fait le projet dans le département
tg on nous dira ça des difficultés je
termine là dessus c'est que nous avions
à nous avions nous avions une
participation financière régionale elle
ne va donc plus être là elle est mis
définitivement enterré suite miami tomas
de cette déviation de canal ville on a
privilégié cette liaison
la desserte des bassins d'emploi en
difficulté 25 à 35 cents à canapville
pour les habitants eh bien chacun
effectivement appréciant et l'on
terminera par sa merci tous les cinq
d'avoir participé à cette émission
spéciale départementale sur les antennes
de france 3 basse-normandie et france
bleu le message on l'a bien compris
c'était celui du début de cette émission
c'est le 22 mars
allez voter pour le premier tour de ces
élections départementales
merci merci à philippe thomas de france
bleu et à guillaume maillard de ouest
france bon week-end et rendez vous le 22
mars pour des soirées spéciales sur nos
antennes respectives
m